twin sisters Lauri and Reba Chappelle
live remarkably typical lies considering
they have an unusual bond they are
conjoined twins and though they share a
significant portion of their brains a
common blood supply and identical DNA
they still maintain their unique
personalities we're so different that
the only thing we have in common is that
we love each other that's about it long
a source of interest and fascination
this rare biological phenomenon occurs
in only about one in 100,000 live births
of these only one in four will survive
their first day there are many different
kinds of conjoined twins each presenting
unique challenges to survival and
mobility where they are connected
determines which vital organs they may
share the key factor in whether they can
be separated after birth when I found
out that the girls were gonna be born
conjoined it was really a scary time and
they just said that your daughters are
conjoined I asked him where and they
said in the chest area
Michelle Roderick and her husband Jeff
fear the worst
if their girls share a single heart
chances of survival are virtually nil
this is
joining the two infants fortunately this
is not the case the girls are linked at
their breast bones livers and diaphragms
they are delivered by c-section without
major complications but there are
worrisome signs Shana wasn't doing so
good
she was slower to come around she was
smaller and having trouble say Jenelle
in this case would get really mad she'd
start just really throwing a fit and
when she cried so hard she would
actually push the surface blood off of
her body and into Shauna's body and
Shauna wasn't crying and alson she just
would turned beet red and Jenelle looked
really scary white the parents and
doctors believe that twins should be
separated as soon as possible the chance
of both twins surviving 60% the overall
surgery was less 7.f hours separating a
liver it took him about three and a half
the operation is traumatic but the twins
survived once they were separated they
actually just would throw a fit because
you know they were used to somebody
right there in their face you know each
other for some twins like Shana and
Jenelle Rodrick separation and intense
reconstructive surgery can lead to great
success
I don't think it's very apparent that
they were conjoined from the outward
appearance there are a few scars that
only are visible if you look for them
out of the socket we're still stuck
together that'll be kind of weird like
my life would be like huh you wouldn't
be able to do a lot of things so happy
that was separated I am at least you can
do whatever you want to do and you don't
have to like be stuck to her when the
risks involved with surgery are too high
however twins must adapt such was the
case with the original so-called Siamese
twins Chang Henning bunker who moved to
the u.s. from Siam in the 19th century
attached to the abdomen by a 6-inch band
of flesh they stayed conjoined for their
long remarkably independent lives Chang
had a drinking problem and did not egg
fathered eleven children while Chang
fathered ten because of their shared
brain tissue separation was not a
possibility for Laurie and Reba Chappell
either and they too have adapted when I
go on a date she is non-existent she
sits there she eat it reads or plays a
game or does something he just totally
zones me out I don't think about being a
contrary twin every day doesn't enter my
mind unless something or somebody brings
it up I am just an average person living
on earth trying to do the best I can
with what I had